You
Among the Divines, the sister Azura would colour the land's
Invertency, fill the blue oceans with life, and instill within these creations the potential
to grow and repopulate.
In her accomplishment, she would be known as the Goddess of Fertility.
In time, Azura's creations would grow in intellect and complexity.
In their scattered tribes, the gods took to guiding humanity with their superior knowledge.
In this exchange, humanity gave them worship and devotion, the gods which shaped the foundations
of human civilization across the lands in each celebrating their divine benefactor.
The gods, confident that mankind could stand on their own, sought to create the heavens,
a place where the gods could raise families of their own kind, as Earth was no space for
them to grow.
They rightfully seeked the same prosperity that they offered for their own and loved.
Out of all the gods, it was Azura who could not leave humanity.
She loved her creations, yet she also loved the gods.
She left a piece of her divinity with her family in remembrance and remained on Earth
to live among humanity, not as a ruler, but as a watcher and caretaker.
It would be after the gods' departure that the long peace would end.
With the imbalance of power, wars between the regions could not be prevented.
Anger, strife, and hunger for power would taint the ego of man, and Azura's limited
power could not restore the will of the gods that left behind for humanity.
In her perceived failure, Azura would seemingly disappear from the walks of history.
It has been long theorized that the goddess still lives amongst us in secret.
There has been a long time speculation that throughout history, Azura has been guiding
humanity in small leadership roles, humanitarian efforts in philanthropy, or using her power
to prevent cataclysmic disasters.
Wherever she is, we can all rest easy that she is watching over us from a position befitting
a goddess among men.
Well, Billy, I think we all learned an important lesson here today.
That's right, Papa. Whatever happens, we're all family.
That's exactly right, Billy, and there's nothing more important than family.
Aw, Shucks, I'm so happy I have such a big, happy loving family.
I'd be such a sucker if I didn't have a family.
Aw, Billy.
It has been a few years since I came to the realization that I could no longer outrun
the reach of mankind.
Living among animals, I tried to run from civilization for as long as time would allow.
I am content to play the role of a commoner among humanity, yet I am tortured still by
loneliness, by desires.
I cannot fight my needs anymore.
I must find my place among the humans and start a family.
In my inaugural efforts to integrate into modern society, it became clear that I lack
the necessary knowledge to fraternize as humans do.
With animals, it's so simple, yet with humans, my knowledge avails me no aid.
Again and again, I accumulated countless attempts at courting a suitable mate.
How could I, before my goddess of fertility, struggle in his venture?
Yet seeing the progress humanity has earned themselves, astonishes me.
They have become creators in themselves, expanding upon the earth we had given them.
The tiny seed I had planted all those eons ago, well how it blossomed.
I had believed my heart broken beyond repair, but living as they do, I see now that they
don't need the wills of higher beings to find their own happiness.
Perhaps this in itself was the will of the gods.
I see now the beauty in the human spirit, for all its ugliness and evil, but also in
its kindness and community.
It is the dichotomy of these aspects that makes them worthy of my love.
I only regret not growing alongside them.
I must make up for lost time, for every kindling of my passion.
I have found I have endless love to give, and give it I shall.
Any takers?
It's a pleasure to finally meet you.
I am Azura.
I bet you feel like devoting yourself to me now, don't you?
Oh, you just came back from an ISE concert?
Did you have fun?
My eyes are up here.
I suppose I don't mind you taking a peek.
After all, I do have two rather big personalities, wouldn't you say?
Oh, you'd make such a perfect servant for me.
Aren't you convinced to serve me at just a glance?
Ah, fine.
If I have to convince you, then it's okay.
Why don't I tell you about myself first?
Wah!
It's me.
Hi.
I hope you enjoyed the crazy concert from ISE,
because now it's time to relax and vibe with me.
My name is Azura Doulay, pronounced Doulay.
Azura for blue and Doulay, which is French for of milk.
So, blue milk.
I bet you're wondering why blue.
Well, because I'm blue.
As for milk, I wonder.
My day of creation is the 21st of August,
which also happens to be National Gold Day.
What are the odds?
You want to know my age?
Well, a goddess lives for so many human years.
It's hard to keep up.
I've long forgotten.
Oh, you're also wondering what type of goddess I am?
I am a goat goddess.
And I've been around for eons.
Did you know goats bring fertility to the land,
and that's exactly what I did to get you here?
I am also 185 centimeters, while around adorable humans like yourself.
But the truth is, this isn't the biggest I can get.
I can be as tall as a skyscraper.
But doing that right now wouldn't be so wise.
I only have English listed because that is what I mainly speak,
but I am currently learning Japanese and Dutch.
Who got hit all the more?
Mina genki de, yate kureru toin de, takeru.
Well, even goddesses have things they like and dislike.
Here are mine.
I love to pamper humans, which also involves nursing you,
while also praising you,
because I love seeing you flustered when I call you a good boy or a good girl.
And did it work?
You are so well-behaved, sitting through my debut.
I really like getting all cuddled up nice and warm together,
and foot massages too, but sometimes it tickles.
So let's not get too carried away.
I do love exotic pets.
I think they're very cute and unique.
I mean, like raccoons, ferrets, axolotls, even snakes and fuzzy spiders too.
Well, I'm sure some of you are going to be very rebellious,
and that's just how some humans are, but why disobey me?
Wouldn't it be nice to feel my warm embrace rather than be scolded by me?
And for those who do not listen, are called stinkers.
So if you don't want to be one, behave.
Next are pickles.
They are disgusting.
Only went on a burger though.
I wouldn't mind sucking on them alone.
But I don't think they taste great with anything else.
And you see, well, I wouldn't be able to present myself in front of you
without the help of some incredibly creative people.
Thank you all so so much for all your hard work and dedication to our creation.
Thank you, Mama.
Thank you, Papa.
And thank you, everyone else.
I truly appreciate you.
Oh, and I can't wait to tell you about my interests.
I'm a huge anime fan, and I'm not picky either.
I have watched over thousands of anime, love, comedy, adventure, action,
and especially a good revenge story.
My all-time favorite, it's Tsukumichi Moonlight Fantasy.
The ancient Magus Bride, and the world god only knows.
As for games, the relaxed and chill ones are my go-to most of the time,
but I don't shy away from kicking some butt now and then.
All my topics are Minecraft, starting Valley, and League.
I mean, The Sims! The Sims!
Yeah!
I've also got so many great things on my mind,
but here are some of my goals.
I can't wait to achieve with you all.
Like, reading bedtime stories so you can get the best sleep,
but play all yours and my favorite games,
grow a big loving community,
and I absolutely can't wait to fulfill your requests for all kinds of ASMRs.
For the more exclusive ASMRs, you'll find them over on the Patreon.
Not to mention, I would love to collaborate with other amazing creators.
Workout streams as an ASMR are something I'm very interested in,
and I can't wait to try out with you all.
Let's get fit together.
And last but definitely not least,
making so many precious memories with all of you.
And here are my tags.
Tags haven't been decided yet,
but I was hoping that we could all come up with some,
which we will do in 2.0.
So far, we have, of course, our June tag indulge,
our art tag Azul Arts,
for all your favorite works devoted to me,
and our NSW tag Azul Leagues
for the more spicier works of art, or mentions.
Some ideas for tags are live Azul Live,
the clips Daily Delay,
and the memes are Azul Meme or Delay Last.
Since we are limited in time, I do hope you understand,
so please help me come up with the rest in 2.0, okay?
Here would be our fandom,
but we have now is Bleeding Hearts.
If you guys have other ideas, I'd love to hear them in 2.0.
As for my Oshimarks, it is a goat emoji,
because, you know, I'm the goat.
The milk bottle emoji to represent you guys,
my little babes.
Azul, look at our mascot!
Aren't they so cute?
They're big ears and absorb a little face and fits you.
Oh, let me tell you about my genmets.
First, there is Meme, very creative.
The things I've seen her do are out of this world,
yet she's also a funny little oddball,
and sometimes surprisingly chill.
However, I'm really worried about what you'll do with that hammer.
I see. I love this cute roll of love,
but I swear she has a menace to food.
Some of her old food combinations are insane and traumatized me.
I really love her big claws, though.
And she be.
She's so funny and says the wildest jokes that really catch me off guard.
Her extremely high energy pulls you in,
and I can see her getting into trouble a lot.
And she's definitely the biggest yapper.
Her ears look so soft, and I want to stroke them.
Then there's Mercy.
She's the most adorable thing I've met.
So sweet.
So yummy.
And last but not least, Strony.
I truly hard-working fish,
but I sometimes worry about how much rest she's been getting.
Maybe I'll help her out and relieve some stress.
I love all my gen mates very, very much.
Now come, let's head over to my room.
Welcome to my room.
Feel free to have a look around.
Isn't it spacious?
As all the things I need and like.
A great view from the balcony.
Watch yourself up there, though.
You might fall.
There is a big comfy bed with lots of pillows.
Good for many things, yeah?
Food to snack on.
And my personal favorite, a large, steaming hot bath.
It's perfect for relaxing after a long day,
and it has my favorite scent, lavender.
Oh, me?
I'm wearing only what I need to.
Too many clothes, just getting the way.
It might not be much, but it's made from the best material around.
Of course, I like to decorate my hair.
Just look.
My horns are no exception.
Aren't they pretty?
I'm a big fan of jewels, you know.
Oh, and how could I forget my rings?
That's right.
Toe rings.
Are they just wonderful?
I hope you like my looks.
But that's not all.
I'm very ex-brushes, goddess.
You know, you'll get to see my...
little face.
My angry face.
My dark face.
When I cry.
When I'm shocked.
And when I sweat.
My dead fish eyes.
And when I'm confused.
And when I'm blustered.
Or how about when I'm in love.
Or even wanting more.
I hope all of you love...
of all of you love my beautiful expressions.
But one thing I never go anywhere without
is some emergency milk.
And some...
And here is my schedule for the week.
Tomorrow is debut 2.0.
And I'll share some of my more interesting things with you then.
Monday will play a place forbidden.
And then after a day of rest, I have my very first ASMR stream for you all.
Followed by one shot, some more one shot.
And then some relaxing supermarket simulator
where I'll sell my top tear milk.
Wow, I'm getting a little sleepy.
Sadly, that's all I've got time for my darlings.
But if you like and subscribe, you can get a whole lot more of me very soon.
The fun isn't over though.
Because next we have Mercy to give you entertainment.
Just watch out though.
She's not as soft as me.
In fact, I would describe her as very...
Sharp.
So please stay a while as the read-it direct will take some time.
See you very soon, my lovelies.
Bye bye!
Thank you for watching!